etwas ganz wichtiges vergessen
freunde der sonne herzlich willkommen zu
advent chemie teil 2 heute videos des
justus ist eine hawaiianische
drachenbaum nur heute wird er zu
weihnachtsbaum legen das ja bestimmt
auch pinch ist oder auch hier auf
youtube gibt es ganz viel die
weihnachtsdeko die sie zwar schön aus
aber ihr habt einfach keinen bock zu
basteln deswegen machen wir es heute
anders und ich zeige euch heute die
weihnachtsdeko die zwar nicht so schön
aussieht aber dafür richtig bock macht
weil chemie also erstmal braucht er
mindestens ein paar lichter schön jetzt
muss justus natürlich auch geschmückt
werden
chemiker ist dahin könnt ihr auch ganz
einfach zu hause nachmachen man nimmt
kalium aluminium sofort destilliertes
wasser erhitzt das ganze bis sich löst
das ist abkühlen nimmt viele anhänger
und stäbchen vergehen ein glas dies die
abgekühlte lösung rein macht es noch ein
paar mal schläft nachts rüber und am
nächsten tag hat man wunderschöne
anhänger mit kristallen die ein bisschen
aussehen wie zucker die man aber nicht
essen sollte lassen sich nicht so gut
schmecken
so das sieht jetzt schon sehr schön aus
aber ich glaube es fehlt ein bisschen
winter player was ist schon weihnachten
ohne schnee doch justus der
hawaiianische drachenbaum mag schnee sei
nichts zu sehen
zum glück bin ich heli karin und kann
kunstschnee herstellen
higgs frage an euch was war das für ein
magic pulver mit dem ich in den schnee
gemacht habe und wie funktioniert es
genau
kleiner tipp es funktioniert ganz
ähnlich wie dieser beauty blende so
eigentlich wollte ich muss noch ein paar
künstliche eisberge da unten hin sitzen
doch leider ist mir dass ihr passiert
frage an euch was ist hier drin
tipp 1 es entstand im letzten weihnachts
video im teil 1 im tipp nummer zwei es
ist schön war steht jetzt aber mal hier
den schnee
ich hab ich ja gesagt das wird heute
nicht so schön
also leute jede korrekte chemische
erklärung in den kommentaren kriegt von
mir persönlich einen keks energiewende
nach erklärungen sucht aber keine herz
dann schaut doch mal in die kommentare
reichen wir haben hier eine sehr schlaue
community bleibt sicher freunde wir
sehen uns in der endphase
freud mir auf instagram